I rather like I always like the
quotation that Franklin Franklin
Roosevelt said I mean I this I keep he
said it's one of my favorites
during the Depression he said that he
said it is common sense to take a method
and try it if it fails admit it frankly
and try another
but above all try something say that is
what's going on today I think it is I
think it is and I hope it is it is the
professionals of many many many
different professions in their technical
work are in a sense helping build a kind
of tapestry of practices rules
regulations customs agreements and
working arrangements
some are local some are national some
regional some are informal some are
formal and like that tapestry of
Penelope it sometimes comes very much
undone in the middle of the night well
when it's undone in the middle of the
night we try something else and we try
it again the next day but we keep on
going
that's Roosevelt and that is what I
think is at stake that rule of law and
that's not easy that's not easy a rule
of law now I can't give a talk of them
in America without people thinking what
we have it it's obvious it's a or we'd
like the air we breathe
yah-yah-yah wasn't always it isn't
always in all parts of the world it's
hard I mean this document this document
was written Madison Hamilton and the
others and why did they give the supreme
court the power to declare
unconstitutional a law of Congress not
Madison thought we've written a Hamilton
thought we've written a beautiful
document here which is true I think it
is beautiful document but if people can
just jump outside the boundaries that it
traces we might as well hang it up in
the museum we'll put it in the
Smithsonian he didn't actually say
Smithsonian because it wasn't built in
but you get the idea
so he says somebody has to have the
power to say when other parts of the
government or themselves have gone too
far now should that be the president no
he has too much power already and we
better be careful he'll just say
everything he does is constitutional
what about Congress they're elected by
the people
well he says that's a good idea as long
as what you want is popular but the
words here are just as binding in
respect to the least popular person in
the United States as the most so we can
trust them if it's popular but what if
it isn't then they're the judges not
that the judges are so wonderful but
they're the ones who are left there gray
he says nobody knows who they are and
they don't have the power of the purse
and they don't have the power of the
sword so they won't have used their
power that's what he says in the
Federalist Papers great yeah that's what
they did that's what they did it wasn't
just Marbury in Madison and just as
marshal who made this up but he didn't
ask this question because he couldn't
give the power to the judges mm-hmm we
have Hotspurs question Henry for part
one Owen Glendower who is a Welsh
general and a mystic is all Welshman are
mystics basically for Shakespeare anyway
he says I can summon demons from the
vasty deep and Hotspur who is your
practical Englishman says well so can I
so can any man but will they come when
you do call for them good point and
indeed in the early part of our history
the Supreme Court said the Cherokee
Indians owned northern Georgia and the
President Andrew Jackson said John
Marshall the Chief Justice has made his
decision now let him enforce it and he
sent troops to carry out the decision no
to evict the Indians who traveled along
the Trail of Tears
to Oklahoma where those who survived
very few lived to this day with our
descendants
and we did have a civil war and we did
have 80 years of segregation and it was
touch-and-go when the court said the
segregation racial segregation is
unconstitutional whether that holding of
the court would be followed or not my
own mind a key moment the judge in
Little Rock Arkansas says integrates
54 was a decision 55 nothing happened
56 nothing happened 1957 the judge says
integrate Central High School and the
governor Faubus stands on the door
Stefan says no he may have the law I
have the troops the state militia an
Eisenhower got involved and he went to
see Eisenhower he said I'll do it I'll
do it I'll integrate I'll integrate he
went outside told the press the opposite
and Eisenhower was pretty angry and
after advice Jimmy Byrnes who'd been on
the Supreme Court governor moderate race
governor of South Carolina said to
President Eisenhower if you send troops
you will have to reoccupy the whole
South now are you ready for a second
reconstruction and he said well the best
that will happen is they'll close all
the schools mm-hmm nobody will be
educated about Eisenhower did send the
troops he took the hundred and first
Airborne those where everybody knew that
in 1957 who they were they were the
paratroopers who had gotten hung up on
the steeples in Normandy and they fought
here in the Battle of the Bulge no they
were heroes he taught a thousand of them
they went on airplanes they took those
nine brave black children by the hand
and they went into the school how I'd
like to end the story there but I can't
because what happened next was a
segregationist board is elected they
closed the schools they refused to
follow the order it goes up to the
Supreme Court
the Supreme Court says you have to
integrate that Central High School all
nine judges signed the opinion very
unusual all nine sign their names and
but after all nine nine it could have
been nine thousand judges this is the
south it's a large part of the United
States well I think by then however and
he closed the schools the next day
governor Faubus closed the schools and
nobody was educated for a year mm-hmm
read the history of that it's a pretty
sad history but I think the die was cast
you see they couldn't keep it they had
to reopen the schools they did and that
was the days of Martin Luther King in
the days of the Freedom Riders and the
days when there was an enormous movement
politically across the country to be
sure that the South got rid of that
legal segregation alright so I once
asked my aspirin and Jordan who'd been a
big civil rights person at that time do
you think the Supreme Court decision
really made a difference given all the
things that followed and his answer was
of course it made a difference of course
perhaps as a catalyst but it made a
difference and I think that's true
you